lest anyone accuse us of being too tough
on mr biden today i have invited on my
friend a true a card-carrying democrat
ethan baerman very well-known democrat
lawyer you've seen him on fox news and
lots of tv shows
ethan thank you for coming on
michael look it's uh if we weren't
friends i wouldn't be here but here we
are and
i always appreciate you inviting me on i
mean that so it's good to see you today
and i'm glad you're doing well well
thank you for coming on i
this is not even a debate this one
sometimes we do these debate kind of
segments this is not even a debate this
is me in all sincerity and all sweet
little innocents
one is there still an argument that
democrats can be making for joe biden
whether we're talking about joe biden as
the nominee in 2024 whether we're
talking about joe biden campaigning for
dems in 2022 whether we're talking about
the job joe biden is doing is there an
argument that that democrats can still
be making for joe biden and if there is
what is it
yeah i mean that i appreciate you asking
the question and i think that there's a
very strong one first if you ignore the
endless 24-hour drum beat since the day
he was elected from right-wing media
which only speaks negatively of him
let's be clear he passed the
infrastructure bill 1.2 trillion dollars
got that done that the previous
president kept talking about for four
years joe biden got that done he got the
burn pit act passed he actually takes
care of our military veterans the
largest expansion of va benefits in over
a generation we have the lowest
unemployment rate so if you're going to
use that reagan quote people aren't
losing their jobs right now for the most
part of course there's always limited
segments of the economy losing their
jobs 3.6 percent unemployment rate lower
than the pre previous president's lowest
unemployment rate let's add a really
huge one into that as well
we had
russia invade an independent
sovereign nation who is an ally we
signed a 1994 treaty with called ukraine
and
biden
pulled together the largest coalition in
the west
since world war ii
to defend in europe to defend against
this invasion to send arms to train
to send aid we have been
helping our ukrainian friends i don't
even think we've been helping enough but
that's my own personal opinion yeah
there are huge things in biden's favor
by the way you missed one key poll
in your citation there mr knowles which
goal is that there was just a poll done
head to head joe biden against ron
desantis joe biden against donald trump
gavin newsom who i know you particularly
love to pick on news
desantis and trump and they both beat
trump and desantis
so
despite the approval rating polls
despite the issues polls you're saying
look once they go up against these
republicans especially that dirty rotten
trump but desantis also though there
have been polls like that new hampshire
poll that came out a couple of weeks ago
that puts desantis ahead of joe biden
but you say look you go up against the
real republicans the democrats are going
to win i must have pushed back a little
bit on ukraine
let's not forget that mr zielinski the
president of ukraine did say that the
immediate cause of the war in ukraine
was the easing of sanctions western
specifically american sanctions against
russia and the green lighting of the
nordstrom 2 oil pipeline those are
zolensky's words not mine that was
something that joe biden did he then
not only
figuratively or
sort of uh in a modest indirect way
invited putin to invade ukraine but then
when he was asked will you react if
putin invades ukraine he said that if it
were only a minor incursion he wouldn't
do very much uh which seems to me to be
a direct invitation regardless of all
that uh yes biden now is uh governing
after the coronavirus lockdown so he did
push for some more restrictive measures
he's still they're reopening the economy
unemployment is low sure but surely you
have to admit ethan the economy
it's not it's not going well we've got
record high inflation we've got uh
record high gas prices record high food
prices right it's not going well right
so
the economy is exceptionally complex so
if we want to discuss certain key data
points look i was the one that went on
fox news last summer as a democrat and
said
biden is wrong
and his administration i should say was
wrong to say that inflation was just
transitory and it didn't really mean
much so i absolutely agree that
inflation is a very serious
direct issue to individual americans and
to the economy as a whole there is
absolutely no denying that and anybody
who does i believe is either just a pure
partisan hack or a liar
um and so i never
will espouse that statement so i agree
with you that the inflation is i but
however somebody who works with
businesses across many sectors as i have
i also worked in the supply chain
during the epidemic trying to get
products from china as an attorney
helping people and i'm going to just
tell you something the pandemic
dramatically and right now china still
has lockdowns going on and if the
overwhelming majority of our products
are still coming from china by the way
manufacturing
facility construction under joe biden in
the united states is up 116
so that's another victory for joe biden
that you haven't mentioned we're
bringing manufacturing back under joe
biden the keratin stick approach has
worked and it was trump who put the
tariffs on chinese products which
directly are paid for by the u.s
consumer so the pandemic altered the
global supply chain the uk has higher
inflation countries around the world
have higher inflation canada has higher
inflation than the united states right
now it's not a joe biden issue it's a
global issue and joe biden has done
things to help the supply chain in the
united states by incentivizing
manufacturing companies as i just
mentioned manufacturing is up in the
united states he's helped the ports here
on the west coast to move the products
through faster he did that last summer
here at the port of long beach and port
of los angeles in particular
which are the major gateways for for the
east asian products of which americans
continue to buy so from that perspective
joe biden has actually done a very good
job
inflation and corporate profits are at
record highs remember corporate profits
according to the wall street journal not
a left-leaning publication are the
highest they have been since the early
1960s so
surely ethan you would have to admit
when we're talking about inflation you
can't have that conversation without
energy prices it would seem pretty clear
to me joe biden has opposed the
expansion of the most
reliable sources of american energy he
shut down the oil pipelines he shut down
new oil and gas leases in the united
states are you saying there's there's no
effect here are you saying that had
biden not had a more open energy policy
and instead of green lighting pipelines
for russia he greenlit some pipelines in
the united states instead of shaking
down iran for oil he produced oil in the
united states you don't think that would
have any effect i guess we're out of
time but i on that point i i would ask
this
additional question which is
if everything's going so well for joe
biden why are democrats looking so bad
historically bad in the generic midterm
polls why why are the republicans
looking at picking up potentially 40 to
60 seats in the house according to not
just the right-wing polls but the
left-wing polls as well if things are
going so well for biden why do the
people seem to be looking for two
republicans in 2022
well midterms first term midterms are
historically bad they were for trump as
well after holding all three uh houses
in the air two houses in the executive
branch that is a common problem and
again if we get a 24-hour dump drum beat
from most outlets including social media
remember top posts on facebook are
right-wing posts from your pal in
particular here at the daily wire sure i
will look but i have to correct this a
little bit i mean you're right we do
extremely well on social media
especially on facebook but when you're
talking about the daily wire or dan
bongino or a couple of other people
compared to abc nbc cbs cnn msnbc the
new york times was it's not even close
the vast vast majority of social media
posts that get traction are left-wing
there there are just more of those
outlets so i mean if if your argument
ethan is that the media
is overwhelmingly or even even close to
right wing that seems
like a difficult argument to make it's
not and if you and you actually you made
a statement earlier that said that the
the heads at cnn are so liberal i
actually disagree with you um and i
don't believe that that is an accurate
statement anymore that might have been
an accurate statement a few years ago i
don't believe it is anymore um based on
my own knowledge and experience so we
can have that argument separately and i
thank you for inviting me on michael i i
really do appreciate it i love that we
have this conversation ethan you you
have made the strongest argument for joe
biden that i have heard truly you have i
think you've laid out all of the
doesn't exactly persuade me but i do i
very much appreciate it appreciate you
coming on and making it and we'll see
you next time
thanks michael if you enjoyed that video
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content out there
[Music]
[Music]
you